ladies and gentlemen when I first
encountered the name of the city of
Stockholm I little thought that I would
end up visiting it never mind end up
being welcomed as a guest of the Swedish
Academy and the Nobel Foundation at that
particular time such an outcome was not
just beyond expectation it was beyond
conception in the 1940s when I was the
eldest child of an ever-growing family
in rural County Derry we crowded
together in three rooms of a traditional
thatched farmstead and lived a kind of
den life which was more or less
emotionally and intellectually proofed
against the outside world it was an
intimate physical creaturely existence
in which the night signs of the horse in
the stable beyond one bedroom wall
mingled with the sons of adult
conversation from the kitchen beyond the
other we took in everything that was
going on of course rain in the trees
mice on the ceiling a steam train
rumbling along the railway line one
foetus back from the house but we took
it in as if we were in a doze of
hibernation a historical pre sexual in
suspension between the archaic and the
modern we were susceptible and as
impressionable as the drinking water
that stood in a bucket in our scullery
every time a passing train made the
earth shake the surface of that water
would ripple delicately concentrically
and in perfect silence but it wasn't
only the earth that shook for us the
earth that I beg your pardon the air
around
and above us was alive and signaling
also when a wind stirred the beaches it
also stirred the aerial wire attached to
the topmost branch of the chestnut tree
darkness swept in through the whole
board in the corner of the window frame
right on into the innards of our
wireless set for a little pandemonium of
burbles and squeaks would suddenly give
way to the voice of the BBC newsreader
speaking out of the unexpected like a
deus ex machina and that voice too we
could hear in our bedroom transmitting
from beyond and behind the voices of the
adults in the kitchen just as we could
often hear behind and beyond every voice
the frantic piercing signaling of Morse
code we could pick up the names of our
neighbors being spoken in the local
accents of our parents and in the
resonant English tones of the newsreader
the names of bombers and of cities
bombed of war fronts and of army
divisions of numbers of planes lost and
of prisoners taken of casualties
suffered and advances made and always of
course we would pick up also those other
solemn and oddly bracing words the enemy
and the Allies but even so none of the
news of these world spasms entered me as
terror if there was something ominous in
the newscasters tomes there was
something torpid about our understanding
of what was at stake
and if there was something culpable
about such political ignorant at that
time there or something positive about
the security I inhabit it as a result of
it the war time in other words was pre
reflective time for me preliterate
prehistorical in a way
then was the years went on and my
listening became more deliberate I would
climb up on the arm of the big sofa to
get my ear closer to the wireless
speaker but it was not still news that
interested me what I was after was the
thrill of a story such as a detective
serial about a British special agent
called dick Barton serve an Irish name
come to think of it or perhaps a radio
adaptation of Captain w/e Jones's
adventure tales about an RAF RAF flying
ace called Biggles no that the other
children were older of course there was
much more going on in the kitchen so I
had to get close to the actual radio set
in order to concentrate my hearing and
in that intent proximity to the dial
I grew familiar with the names of
foreign stations of leap zigged and Oslo
Stuttgart and Warsaw and of course with
Stockholm I also get used to hearing
short bursts of foreign languages as the
dial hands swept Rowan from BBC two
radio Erin as Irish radio was called
then from the intonation of London to
the intonation of Dublin and even though
I didn't understand what was being said
in those first encounters with the
gutturals
and sibilants of European speech I had
already begun my journey into the
whiteness of the world
this in turn became a journey into the
whiteness of language a journey where
each point of arrival whether in one's
poetry or one's life each point of
arrival turned out to be a stepping
stone rather than a destination and it
is that journey which is brought me now
to this honored spot and yet the
platform here feels to me more like a
Space Station really
without a stepping stone so that is why
for once in my life I am permitting
myself the luxury of walking on air
I credit poetry for making this
spacewalk possible I credit it
immediately because of a line I wrote
fairly recently encouraging myself and
whoever else might be listening to do
just that
walk on air against your better judgment
the lion said but I credit it ultimately
because poetry can make an order as true
to the impact of external reality and
the sensitive to the inner laws of the
poets being as the ripples that rippled
in and out across the water in that
scullery bucket fifty years ago an order
where we can at last grow up to that
which we stored up as we grew an order
which satisfies all that is a pet ative
in the intelligence and prehensile in
the affections a credit poetry in other
words for being both itself and for
being a help for making possible a fluid
and restorative relationship between the
mind center and its circumference
between the child gazing at the word
stockholm on the face of the radio dial
the man facing the faces that he meets
in stockholm at this most privileged
moment I credit it because credit is due
to it in our time and in all time for
its truth to life and every sense of
that phrase to begin with I wanted that
truth to life to possess a concrete
reliability and I rejoiced most when the
poem seemed most direct an upfront
representation of the world it stood in
for or stood up for or stood its ground
against even as a schoolboy I loved John
Keats as Oh
to autumn for being an ark of the
covenant as it were between language and
sensation as an adolescent as of Jared
Manley Hopkins for the intensity of his
exclamations which were also equations
for the rupture an ache I didn't know I
knew until I read him I loved Robert
Frost for his farmers accuracy and his
wily down-to-earth myths and Chaucer in
fact for much the same reason later on I
would find a different kind of accuracy
a moral down-to-earth ness in to which I
responded deeply and always will in the
poetry of Wilfred Owen the war poet of
the First World War the English war fort
a poetry were a New Testament
sensibility absorbs the shock of the new
center century's barbarism and then
later again in the pure consequence of
Elizabeth Bishop style in the sheer
obduracy of Robert Lowell's and in the
barefaced confrontation of Patrick
cavernous I encountered further reasons
for believing in poets breeze ability
and its responsibilities variously to
say what happens to pity the planet to
be in Wilfred Owen's words not concerned
with poetry so this temperamental
disposition towards an art that was
earnest and devoted to things as they
are this was certainly corroborated by
the experience of having been born and
brought up in Northern Ireland and
having lived with that place though not
in it
for the last quarter of a century no
place in the world prides itself more on
its vigilance and its realism no place
considers itself more qualified to
censure any flourish of rhetoric or any
extravagance of aspiration so partly as
a result of having internalized these
attitudes and partly as a result of
growing a skin to protect myself against
them I went for years half avoiding
half resisting the opulence and
extensiveness of poets as different as
wallace stevens and rainer maria rilke
crediting insufficiently the brilliance
the inwardness the crystalline
inwardness of emily dickinson for those
forked lightnings and fishers of
association missing the visionary
strangeness even in TS Eliot and these
more or less cost of attitudes that I
had in the beginning were fortified by a
refusal to grant the poet any license
anymore license than any other citizen
and further induced by having to conduct
himself as the years went on having to
conduct for himself in a situation of
ongoing political violence and public
expectation a public expectation it has
to be said not of poetry as such but of
political positions variously approvable
by mutually disapproving groups in such
circumstances the mind longs to repose
in what Samuel Johnson called with great
superb confidence the stability of truth
even as it recognizes the destabilizing
nature of its own operations and
inquiries without needing to be
theoretically instructed consciousness
quickly realizes that it is the site of
variously contending discourses the
child in the bed room listening
simultaneously to the debate domestic
idiom of his Irish home and the official
idioms of the British broadcaster while
picking up from behind both signals of
some other distress that child was
already being schooled for the
complexities of an adult predicament a
future where he would have to adjudicate
between promptings among different
promptings variously ethical esthetical
moral political men
Trickle skeptical cultural topical
typical post-colonial and taken all
together simply impossible and so it was
that I find myself in the mid-1970s in
another small house this time in County
Wicklow south of Dublin with a young
family of my own this time I'm just
slightly less imposing radio set
listening to the rain and the trees and
to the news of bombings closer to home
not only those by the Provisional IRA in
Belfast
but equally atrocious results in those
days in Dublin by loyalist
paramilitaries from the north feeling
puny in my predicaments as I read about
the tragic logic of oh man - times
fate in the 1930s feeling challenged yet
steadfast in mine own combatant status
when I heard for example that one
particularly sweet natured school friend
had been interned without trial because
he was suspected of having been involved
in a political killing while I was
longing for was not quite stability but
an active escape from the quicksand of
relativism a way of crediting poetry
without anxiety or apology in a poem
called exposure I wrote these stanzas if
I could come on meteorite instead I
walked through damp leaves husks the
spent flux of autumn imagining a hero on
some muddy compound his gift like a
sling stone quill for the desperate how
did I end up like this I often think of
my friends beautiful prismatic consoling
and the anvil brains of some who hate me
as I sit weighing and weighing my
responsible Chrystia for what
for the ear for the people for what is
said behind bikes rain comes down
through the alders it's low conducive
voices muttering let downs and erosions
and yet each drop recalls that diamund
absolutes
I am neither internally nor Informer an
inner Amy gray grown long-haired
unthoughtful a wood Karen escaped from
the massacre taking protective coloring
from Boleyn bark feeling every wind that
blows whoo
blowing up these sparks for their meager
heat have missed the once-in-a-lifetime
portent the Comets pulsing Rose in one
of the poems best known to my generation
of Jordan and a form which could be said
to have taken the nutrients as it were
of the symbolist movement and made made
them available in capsule form for
students and the American poet Archibald
MacLeish affirmed that poetry should be
equal to not true as a defiant defiant
statement of poetry's gift for telling
truth for telling it slant this is both
cogent and corrective yet there are
times when a deeper need enters when we
want the poem not only to be pleasurably
right but compellingly wise not only a
surprising variation played upon the
world but a retuning of the world itself
we want the surprise to be transitive
if you like like the impatient thump
that unexpectedly restores the picture
to the television set or the electric
shock that sets the fibrillating heart
back to its proper rhythm we want what
the woman wanted in the prison cue in
Leningrad standing there blue with cold
and whispering for fear enduring the
terror of Stalin's regime
and asking the poet Anna Akhmatova if
she could describe it all if her art
could be equal to it
and this is the once I too was
experiencing and those far more
protected circumstances in County
Wicklow when I wrote the lines have just
quoted and these four poetry that would
merit the definition I gave a few
moments ago poetry as an order true to
the impact of external reality and
sensitive to the inner laws with the
poet's being the external reality an
inner dynamic of happenings in Northern
Ireland between 1968 and 1974 were
symptomatic of change violent change
admittedly but changed nevertheless and
for the minority living their change had
been long overdue it should have come
early as the result of the ferment of
protests on the streets in the late 60s
but that was not to be and the eggs of
danger which were always incubating but
hatched out quickly when the Christian
moralist in oneself was impelled to
deplore the atrocious nature of the iras
campaign of bombings and killings and
they so to speak mere Irish and oneself
was appalled by the ruthlessness of the
British Army on occasions like Bloody
Sunday in Derry
in 1972 the minority citizen in oneself
the one who had grown up conscious that
his group was distrusted and
discriminated against in all kinds of
official and unofficial ways this
citizens perception was at one with the
truth the poetic truth of the situation
in recognizing that if life in Northern
Ireland
were ever really to flourish change how
to take place but that citizens
perception was also at one with the
truth in recognizing that the very
brutality of the means by which the IRA
was pursuing change was destructive of
the trust upon which new possibilities
would have to be based
nevertheless until the British
government caved in to these strong-arm
tactics of the Ulster loyalist workers
after the Sunningdale conference in 1974
a well disclosed mine could still hope
to make sense of circumstances to
balance what was promising with what was
destructive and do what wb8 had tried to
do a century before namely to hold in a
single thought reality and justice after
1974 however and for 20 long years
between then and the ceasefires of
august 1994 such a hope proved
impossible the violence from below was
then productive of nothing but a
retaliatory violence from above the
dream of justice became subsumed into
the callousness of reality and people
settled into a quarter century of light
namely to hold in a single thought
reality and justice after 1974 however
and for 20 long years between then and
the ceasefires of august 1994 such a
hope proved impossible the violence from
below was then productive of nothing but
a retaliatory violence from above the
dream of justice became subsumed into
the callousness of reality and people
settled into a quarter century of life
waste and spirit waste of hardening
attitudes and narrowing possibilities
all the natural result of political
solidarity traumatic suffering and sheer
emotional self protectiveness
one of the most harrowing moments in the
whole harrowing of the heart in Northern
Ireland came when a minibus full of
workers were being driven home one
January evening in 1976 and the bus was
then held up by armed and masked men and
the occupants of the van were ordered at
gunpoint to line up on the side of the
road then one of the masked men the
executioner sort of speak said to them
any Catholics among you step out here as
it happened this particular group with
one exception were all Protestants so
the presumption must have been that the
masked men were Protestant
paramilitaries about to carry out a
tit-for-tat
sectarian killing of the Catholic as the
odd man out the one who would have been
presumed to be in sympathy with the IRA
and all its actions it was a terrible
moment for him caught between dread and
witness if you like but he did make a
motion to step forward and then the
story goes he felt the hand of a
Protestant worker and the relative cover
of the evening darkness he felt this
hand next to him take his hands squeeze
it and a signaler said no don't move
when a betrayer you only need to know
what faith you are what party you belong
to all in vain however because the man
had stepped out of line but instead of
finding a gun at his temple he was
pushed away and the gunman opened fire
on those remaining in the line for these
were not Protestant terrorists but
members presumably of the Provisional
IRA
it is difficult at times to repress the
thought that history is about as
instructive as an abattoir that Tacitus
was right and that peace is merely the
desolation left behind after the
decisive operations of merciless power I
remember for example shocking myself
with the thoughts I had about that
friend who was imprisoned in the 70s on
suspicion of having been involved in
political murder I shocked myself by
thinking that even if he were guilty he
might still perhaps be helping the
future to be born breaking the
repressive forms liberating new
potential in the only way that worked
that is to say the violent way which
therefore became by extension the right
way it was like a moment of exposure to
interstellar cold as it were a reminder
of the scary element in which inner
element and outer element in which human
beings must envisage and conduct their
lives but it was only a moment
the birth of the future we desire is
surely in the contraction that that
terrified Catholic felt on the roadside
when another hand gripped his hand it is
not in the gunfire that followed so
absolute and so desolate if also so much
a part of the music of what happens
as writers and readers sinners and
citizens are realism under aesthetics
tense makes us wary of crediting the
positive note the very gunfire braces us
and the atrocious calls forth a sorry
the atrocious the atrocious confers a
great worth on the effort which it calls
forth to confront it we are rightly in
all of the torsions in the poetry of
Paul's alone because and we are rightly
enamored also of this aspiring voice in
Samuel Beckett because these are
evidence that art can rise to the
occasion and somehow be the corollary of
salon stricken destiny as a Holocaust
survivor and a Beckett's demure heroism
as a member of the French Resistance
likewise we are rightly suspicious of
that which gives too much consolation in
these circumstances the very extremity
of our late 20th century knowledge which
puts much of our cultural heritage to an
extreme test only they're very stupid or
they're very deprived can any longer
help knowing that the documents of
civilization have been written in blood
and tears blood and tears no less real
for being very remote and when this
intellectual predisposition who exists
with actualities like Ulster and Israel
and Bosnia and Rwanda and a host of
other wounded spots on the face of the
earth the inclination is not only not to
credit human nature with much
constructive potential but not to credit
anything too positive about the work of
art which i think is why for years I was
bowed to the desk like some monk bowed
over his pre do some dutiful
contemplative pivoting his understanding
in an F and an attempt to bear his
portion of the
eight of the world knowing himself
incapable of heroic virtue or redemptive
effect but constrained by obedience to
the rule to repeat the effort and to
repeat the posture blowing up the sparks
for a meager heat as it were for getting
faith if you like straining towards good
works attending insufficiently to the
diamund absolutes among which absolutes
must be counted the sufficiency of that
which is absolutely imagined and then
finally and happily and not in obedience
to the door or circumstances of my
native province but in despite of them I
straighten up I began a few years ago to
try to make space in my reckoning and
imagining for the marvelous as well as
for the murderous and once again I try
to represent the import of that changed
orientation with a story out of Ireland
this is a story of another monk a monk
called since Kevin holding himself up
valiantly in the posture of endurance it
said that once upon a time sin kevin was
kneeling with his arms stretched out in
the form of a cross in glendalough was
one of most beautiful most wooded watery
places in ireland and a place which we
live close to when we lived in Whitlam
at any rate where as kevin knelt and
prayed with his arms straight start a
blackbird mistook his outstretched hand
for some kind of roost and the black
bird swooped down upon it laid a clutch
of eggs in it and proceeded to nest in
it as if it were the branch of a tree
so then Kevin was constrained by his
faith in the his love of his love all
things great and small his
pity for life as tenderness towards it
this made Kevin stay immobile for hours
and days and weeks holding his hand out
until the eggs were hatched and the
young fledglings were able to fly away
kevin was there true to life if
subversive of common sense if you like
at the intersection between natural
process and the glimpse ideal at all in
the same time a signpost and a reminder
manifesting that order of poetry where
we can at last grow up to that which we
stored up as we grow as in Kevin's story
is as they say a story out of Ireland
but it strikes me it could equally well
have come out of India or Africa or are
they Arctic or the Americas by which I
don't mean simply to consign it to the
topology of folktales or to dispute its
value by question again questioning its
culture born status within a multi
cultural context on the contrary I think
the trustworthiness and the travel
worthiness of this story have to do with
its local setting I can indeed of course
imagine it nowadays this story being
constructed as a deconstructed I beg
your pardon
being deconstructed as a paradigm of
colonialism with Kevin figuring as the
benign imperialist or the missionary in
the wake of the imperialist the one who
intervenes and appropriates the
indigenous life and interferes with the
pristine ecology and I have to admit
indeed that there is an irony in the
fact that it should have been such a one
who recorded and preserved this instance
of the true beauty of the Irish heritage
Kevin's story after all appears in the
writings of a Norman chronicler Gerald's
convinces Gerald the Welshman
one of the people who invaded Ireland in
the 12th century one of the people whom
the Irish language analyst Jeffrey
Keating shot relocating would call five
hundred years later this was Keating's
description of Cambron sirs the bull of
the herd of those who wrote the false
history of Ireland but even so I cannot
still persuade myself that this
manifestation of early Christian
civilization should be construed all
that simply as a way into whatever is
exploitive or barbaric in our history
past and present the whole conception
strikes me rather as being another
example of the kind of work I saw a few
weeks ago in the small Museum in sparta
in Greece in the morning before the news
of this year's Nobel Prize in Literature
was announced and this this was art
which sprang from a cult very different
from the faith espoused by Stan Kevin
yet in it there was a representation of
a rooster bird and an entranced Beast
and the self in rupturing man except
that this time the man was Orpheus and
the rapture came from music rather than
from prayer the work itself was a small
carved relief and I couldn't help making
a sketch of it and I'm neither could I
have copying out the information which
was on the card that identified the
exhibit and was pinned on the wall
decided the image moved me of course
because of its durability and its
antiquity but the description on the
card moved me also because it gave a
name and it gave credence to the switch
I myself have been engaged upon for the
past three decades votive panel the
identification card said
possibly set up to Orpheus by local poet
local work of the Hellenistic period
once again I hope I am NOT being
sentimental or simply fetishizing as we
have learned to say fetishizing the
local I wish instead to suggest that
images and stories of the kind I'm
invoking here do function as bearers of
value the century has witnessed the
defeat of Nazism by force of arms and
the erosion of the Soviet regimes was
caused by among other things the sheer
persistence beneath the imposed
ideological conformity is your
persistence of cultural values and
psychic resistances of the kind that
these stories and images enshrine even
if we have learned to be rightly and
deeply fearful of elevating the cultural
forms and conservatism of any nation
into a normative and exclusive list
system even if we have terrible proof
that pride in the ethnic and religious
heritage can quickly degrade into the
fascistic our vigilance on that score
should not displace our love and our
trust in the good of the indigenous per
se on the contrary a trust in the
staying power and the travel worthiness
of such good should encourage us to
credit the possibility of a world where
respect for every tradition will issue
in the creation and maintenance of
salubrious political space in spite of
devastating and repeated acts of
massacre assassination and extirpation
the huge acts of faith which have marked
new relations for example between
Palestinians and Israelis between
Africans and afrikaners and the way in
which walls of condoning have come down
in Europe iron curtains have opened all
this
inspires a hope that new possibility can
still open up in Ireland as well the
crux of that problem in Ireland involves
an ongoing partition of the island
between British and Irish jurisdictions
and an equally persistent partition of
the affections in Northern Ireland
between the British and the Irish
Heritage's but early every dweller in
the country must hope that the
government involved in the governance of
the country can devise institutions
which will allow that partition to
become a bit more like the net on a
tennis court a demarcation for agile
give-and-take for encounter and
contending prefiguring a future for the
vitality the vitality the vitality that
flowed in the beginning from those
bracing nouns the enemy and the allies
where that might that vitality might
finally derive from less binary and
altogether less binding vocabularies
when the poet WB Yeats student is
platform more than 70 years ago Ireland
was emerging from the throes of a
traumatic civil war that had followed
fast on the heels of a war of
independence fought against the British
the struggle that ensued had been brief
enough it was over by May 1923 some
seven months before Yates sailed for
spell coal but it was bloody savage and
intimate and for generations to come
it would dictate the terms of the
politics of the twenty-six country
thirty-six independent countries of
Ireland that part of the island known
first of all as the Irish Free State and
then subsequently as the Republic of
Ireland Yeats barely alluded to the
civil war or the war of independence in
his Nobel speech nobody understood
better than he the connection between
the construction or destruction of
political order and the funding or fun
during of cultural life but on that
occasion he chose to talk instead about
the Irish dramatic movement his story
was about the creative purpose of that
movement and its historic good fortune
and having not only his own genius to
sponsor it but also the genius of his
friends John Millington Synge and Lady
Augusta Gregory Yates came to Sweden to
tell the world that the local sorry eh
came to Sweden to tell the world that
the local work of poets and dramatists
had been as important to the
transformation of his native place and
times as the ambushes of guerrilla
armies and his boast in that elevated
prose was much the same as the one he
would make in verse more than a decade
later in his poem the municipal gallery
revisited their Yeats presents himself
amongst the portraits and heroic
narrative paintings hanging in the
gallery paintings which celebrate the
events and the personalities of recent
history and all of a sudden
he realizes that something truly
epoch-making
has occurred this is not I say the dead
Ireland of my youth but in Ireland the
poets have imagined terrible and gay and
the poem concludes with two of the most
quoted lines of his entire over think
we're man's glory most begins and ends
and say my glory was I had such friends
and yet expansive and thrilling as these
lines are they are an instance of poetry
flourishing itself rather than proving
itself ultimately they are the poet's
lap of honor and in this respective in
no other they resemble what I am doing
in this lecture in fact I should also
quote here on my own behalf
some other words from the poem you that
would judge me
do not judge alone this book or that
instead I ask you to do what Yeats asked
his audience to do and think of the
achievement of Irish poets and
dramatists and novelists over the past
40 years among whom I am proud to count
great friends in literary matters Ezra
Pound advised against accepting the
opinion of those quote who haven't
themselves produced notable work and it
is advice I have been privileged to
follow since it is the good opinion of
notable workers and not just
notable workers in my own country it is
the good opinion of those that is
fortified my endeavor since I began to
write in Belfast more than thirty years
ago yes however as we know was not all
flourish to the credit of poetry in our
century there must surely be entered in
any reckoning his two great sequences of
poems entitled
219 and meditations in time of Civil War
the latter of which contains the famous
lyric about the bird's nest at his
window for a Starling or stair as
because it in the poem has built in a
crevice in the old wall the point was
then living in a Norman Tower which had
been very much part of the military
history of the country in earlier times
and as his thoughts turned upon the
irony of civilizations being
consolidated by violent and powerful
conquerors who end up commissioning the
artists and the architects he began to
associate the site of the mother bird
feeding its young with the image of the
honeybee an image deeply lodged in
poetic tradition and always suggestive
of a harmonious industrious nurturing
Commonwealth I just read that poem of
the ages section from meditations in
time of civil war the bees build in the
crevices of loosening masonry and there
are the mother birds bring grubs and
flies my wall is loosening honey bees
come build in the empty house of the
stair we are closed in and the key is
turned on our uncertainty somewhere a
man is killed or house burned yet no
clear fact to be discerned come build in
the empty house of the stair a barricade
of stone or wood some 14 days of civil
war
last night they trundle down the road
that dead young soldier in his blood
come build in the empty house of the
stair we had fed the heart on fantasies
the hearts grown brutal from the fair
more substance in our enmities than in
our love
Oh honeybees come build in the empty
house of the stair I've heard this poem
repeated often in whole or in part by
people in Ireland over the past 25 years
and no wonder because it is as tender
minded towards life as Sint Kevin was
and as tough-minded about what happens
in and to life as homer the poem knows
that Massacre will happen again on the
roadside that the workers in the minibus
are going to be lined up and shot just
after quitting time but it also credits
as a reality that squeeze of a hand the
actuality of sympathy and protectiveness
between living creatures it satisfies
the contradictory needs which
consciousness experiences at times of
extreme crisis the need in the one hand
for a truth-telling that will be hard
and retributive and on the other hand
the need not to harden to a point or it
deny or not the need for the minds not
to harden to a point where it denies its
own yearnings for sweetness and trust it
is a proof that poetry can be equal to
and true at the same time an example of
that completely adequate poetry which
the Russian woman sought from Anna
Akhmatova and which William Wordsworth
produced at a corresponding moment of
historical crisis and personal dismay
almost exactly two hundred years ago
when the bard Demodocus things of the
fall of Troy and the slaughter that
accompanied it Odysseus weeps and Homer
says that his tears were like the tears
of a wife on a battlefield weeping for
the death of her husband fallen in the
defense of the city
his famous epic simile continues in
Robert
Fitzgeralds translation as follows at
the sight of the man panting and dying
there she slips down to enfold him
crying out then feels the spears
prodding her back and shoulders and goes
bound into slavery and grief piteous
weeping wears away her cheeks but no
more piteous and Odysseus tears talked
as they where no from the company even
today three thousand years later as we
channel surf over so much live coverage
of contemporary savagery highly informed
but nevertheless in danger of growing
immune familiar to the point of over
familiarity with all newsreels of the
concentration camp and the gue like even
today homers image can still bring us to
our senses the callousness of those
spear shafts on the woman's back and
shoulders survives time and translation
the image has that documentary adequacy
which answers all that we know about the
intolerable but there is another kind of
adequacy which is specific to lyric
poetry this has to do with the temple
inside our hearing as Rilke called it
which the passage of the poem calls into
being it is an adequacy deriving from
what Mandelstam called the steadfastness
of speech articulation from the
resolution and independence that the
entirely realized form sponsors this has
as much to do with the energy released
by linguistic fission and fusion with
the buoyancy generated by cadence and
tone and rhyme and stanza it is as much
to do with that as it has to do with the
poems concerns or the poet's
truthfulness in fact in lyric poetry
truthfulness becomes recognizable as a
ring of truth within the medium itself
and it is that on a peaceable pursuit of
this note and note tuned to its most
extreme in Emily Dickinson and Paul
an Orchestrator to its most opulent in
John Keats it is this which keeps the
poet's ear straining to hear the totally
persuasive voice behind all the other
informing voices which is a way of
saying I have never really quite climbed
down off the arm of that sofa from the
speaker or the wireless I may have grown
more attentive to the news and more
alive to the world history and the world
sorrow behind it but the thing I've
heard by the speaker I strain towards is
still not quite a story
it's still not the story of what's going
on it is more reflexive than that
because as a port I am in fact straining
towards a strain in the sense that the
effort is to repose in the stability
conferred by a musically satisfying
order of songs as if the ripple at its
widest desire to be verified by a
reformation of itself to be drawn in and
drawn out through its point of origin
I also strain towards this in the poetry
I read and I find it for example in the
repetition of that refrain of Yates's
come build in the empty house of the
stair with its tone of supplication its
pivots of strength in the words build
and house and is the acknowledgement of
dissolution in the word empty I find it
in the triangle of forces held an
equilibrium in the triple rhyme of
fantasies enmities and honeybees and in
the sheer in place nests of the whole
poem as a given form within language
poetic form is the ship and the anchor
is it once a buoyancy and a holding
allowing for the simultaneous
gratification of weather is whatever is
centrifugal and centripetal in mind and
body
and it is by such means that yetis work
does what the necessary poetry always
does which is to touch the base of our
sympathetic nature while taking in at
the same time the unsympathetic reality
of the world to which that nature is
constantly exposed the form of the poem
in other words is crucial to poetry's
power to do the thing which always is
and always will be to poetry spread it
the power that is to persuade that
vulnerable part of our consciousness of
its rightness in spite of the evidence
of wrongness all around it the power to
remind us that we are hunters and
gatherers of values that our very
solitudes
and de-stresses are creditable insofar
as they too are an earnest of our
veritable human being thank you very
much